just when you thought Marvel couldn't
get any more secretive a story like this
comes out one Avengers ends game actor
had no idea they were even in the movie
only realizing they were part of the
super-sized superhero flick when I saw
it in theaters the gobsmacked actor in
question
community alum Avett Nicole Brown who
made a cameo appearance at the shield
base Tony Stark and Steve Rogers visits
in the 1970s the trio share an elevator
together during a scene in which Browns
character as she would employee becomes
highly suspicious of the two
time-traveling Avengers during the
last-ditch effort to retrieve the
tesseract and a few extra Pym particles
her suspicions eventually lead shield
higher rubs to try and thwart their
mission you new year not exactly as
Brown explains in an interview of CNN
she knew she was shooting us scenes for
a Marvel movie but she didn't know which
one she would be in when she saw an
infinity war up on the big screen and
realized that she wasn't in it
Brown assumed directors Jaron Anthony
Russo would simply scrapped a cameo but
it turns out that wasn't the case it all
started in October of 2017
two months after principal photography
began on infinity war Joe Russo reached
out to brown and asked if she was
available to film some scenes Brown
recalled I was on the set of the mayor
for ABC and I got a text from Joe Russo
he said hey what are you doing two weeks
from now he said this is it it's your
turn but cuz Marvel and ABC both operate
under the Disney umbrella Brown was able
to reconfigure her schedule traveling to
Atlanta for a couple of days to knock
out the MCU appearance with her fellow
community cast members Danny Pudi Jim
rash and Ken junk having already snagged
cameos in Marvel movies Brown jumped at
the opportunity to join the MCU
she was also keen to reunite with the
Russos who worked as executive producers
on community before being caught up to
Marvel's big leagues she said I don't
dream that big but after the Russos took
over I thought there's a good chance
there's a lot of people on community and
there's not enough movies for everybody
to have a moment so I was excited that I
got my chance
Brown recalls enjoying her time on set
as well as her experience filming a
scene with Downey jr. and Evans whom she
called lovely human beings but she
walked away not knowing exactly what
movie should film the scene for assuming
that should probably pop up in infinity
war Brown was a bit let down when she
didn't see herself on the silver screen
but still felt grateful to have been a
part of
production according to brown I just
said well it was nice it's the thought
that counts and I forgot about it she
got the shock of her life in April 20
nineteen year and a half after she
stepped onto set when she sat down for a
showing of Avengers endgame when the
action shifted to the shield base Brown
knew that her time to shine had finally
come I'm sitting there with a group of
friends in my seat like this is going to
be it oh my god it's an elevator it's me
she later admitted the one regret she
has about the whole experience not going
to the end game premiere while it's
unusual for an actor to not know they're
in a film until they see it in theaters
this doesn't feel too shocking coming
out of Marvel the studio has got an
increasingly secretive over the years
and has garnered a reputation for
keeping things close to the chest
especially in regards to infinity war
and endgame the filmmakers and marketers
purposefully misdirected funder
misleading trailer edits and distributed
fake scripts for the actors filled with
phony twists
there were even moments when the
filmmakers straight-up lied to the
performers about the context of scenes
they were shooting it was all done for
the sake of preventing spoilers from
spilling outs which thankfully didn't
happen that often the occasional Mark
Ruffalo reveal notwithstanding of course
Brown is hardly the first or only actor
to film something for Marvel without
knowing exactly what it was for she's
joined by Captain Marvel herself brie
Larson who filmed scenes for Avengers
ends game without knowing she saves much
of anything about the character or role
in the story I walked on set that I was
like oh crap I'm like in a Marvel movie
right now
Haley it's a similar story for Pepper
Potts actor Gwyneth Paltrow who made a
special appearance in spider-man
homecoming before later swearing up and
down that she wasn't in the movie at
least thought that she could remember
well we were a spider-man together never
on spider-man we were an in spider-man
yes we were while it was apparently
standard procedure to keep actors
oblivious to the specifics of the third
and fourth Avengers movies the
Rousseau's didn't have anything to worry
about when it comes to Brown she
confirmed to CNN that she zipped her
lips immediately after filming her
scenes and kept them that way for nearly
two years according to the actress that
NDA was ironclad I never told anybody
the result was an appearance that wasn't
just a surprise to her friends it was a
surprise to her too
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the Bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]